and left-hander tarik skubal will tow
the rubber for the tigers today making
his 28th appearance 26 start of the
season didn't factor in a decision in
his last outing against pittsburgh on
monday
and we know scoobs is a guy that throws
a lot of fastballs he likes to elevate
the fastballs got a good slider
like that
down goes a rose arena to start the day
the one two
he gets them looking
cruz disagrees for the tampa bay rays
here this afternoon it's going to be
right-hander luis patino
making his 13th overall start of the
season looking for win number five
60 innings of work 62 strikeouts yeah
he's been a little over 70 percent
there's a swing and miss
fastball there to take care of the
leadoff man for the tigers pace of this
game is really quick and that's fun to
watch too
strikes out luplow that's his third
strikeout already
now the 2-2
big hot shot and nico gordon was there
that was hit on a line but nico goodram
positioned perfectly
and denies joey wendell of another hit
first ballot
absolutely after that at some point
and he is out on strikes 98 away takes
care of him
second
strikeout for luis patino
they just got done with each other and
they play again
coming up here shortly
and
candelario is out on strikes that one in
there in 98.
strikes out mejia to start the third
and derrick school is dialed in early
002 to margot foul tipped into the glove
of garneau if that's the day for tarik
skubal it was a heck of a showing had a
right hamstring pull on friday night
and the series open
broken bat
blooper to right field and a diving
attempt goes a ride for margaux
stay there garneau will jog into second
with a one-out double
good effort by margaux but couldn't come
up with it and that's the first hit for
the tigers here today
the 0-2 to victor reyes
that gets away from the catcher mejia
garneau moves up to third good base
running on the part of dustin guerneau
hopefully he will see the ball here
there you go to right field out of line
in an rbi single for victor reyes the
tigers have drawn first blood
and now jose arena is in
to replace
tarik skubal well they're going to
piggyback a couple starters in this game
crews struck out looking his only time
three and one to cruz
that's a long one hit off the fastball
and that baby's gonna go home run
on a 3-1 pitch nelson cruz gets the
range on the board with his 31st home
run of the year that also extends his
hitting streak to nine
27th career home run against the tigers
basically pitch around the bottom of the
zone
ground ball to second
harold castro retires taylor walls
tampa ties it up on nelson cruz's
448th career homer candelario castro
goodrum in the fourth
candelario golfs one to right field it's
deep and that ball's gone
he pounded it he got it to right field
and jamer candelario's 13th of the
season
gives the tigers the lead right back
well he dropped the barrel and he made
good contact here and this ball just
kept carrying
the 1-0 badoo a rope to right that one's
down reyes will try to go to third and
he will cruise into third base with a
head first slide runners at the corners
for the tigers here in the fifth as they
look for more
[Applause]
foul ball right side and hey that ball
grabbed
by luplow right there at the last moment
realizing he still had a play on that
ball got that mitt down there
and boy that is a big out to get scope
kevin cash marching to the mound
that's gonna be it for luis patino
gets one out leaves two men on here in
the fifth inning
ground ball left side
down to second one there first they got
the double play and it was not a routine
double play
boy that's exactly what the rays needed
right there as grossman grounds into two
crews struck out looking against tarik
skubal in the first and then as we
mentioned the home run
off arena to lead off the fourth
the home run traveled 400 feet there
goes margot the throw from garneau good
throw in time to get him
right on the money from dustin garneau
great play it was a good jump
from manuel
margot
and dustin
garno threw a perfect strike down to
harold castro
the one catching the harold castro and
that'll be the easiest double play of
the tigers
boast all season
wendell hit it right on the nose but
right at harold castro here's brett
phillips
with meadows aboard
phillips lifts the fly ball into left
that sends grossman back to the wall and
it is gone
opposite field home run for brett
phillips
and the rays will take the lead
and just like that
three pitches into the eighth the rays
lead three to two
there's a ground ball that's going to
bound off the glove of candelario one
runner's in here comes the other runner
in and the raves will grab two more to
make it a four-run inning well
everybody's excited here at the ballpark
to watch maggie and what he can do here
right up the middle
scope is home
grossman will stop at third miguel
cabrera comes through with a two-run
single to get the tigers to within one
the one-o to harold castro
a drive
right field and it's caught
[Music]
brett phillips caught it on the warning
track all the way here comes derek hill
he stumbles his way and he's in safely
to tie it at five
this is the response we were talking
about
that the tigers have shown time and time
again this year the runners aboard yep
so here it is soto and diaz first and
third and a liner base hit back into
center field
the reigns will take the lead with choi
crossing the plate and diaz winding up
at second driving in the go ahead run
and there's some con contact off the
glove of soto
a run is gonna score
so cruz crosses the plate the rays got
the second run of the inning and now we
go to the bottom of the 10th inning
scopes the runner catrice back out on
the hill and the first pitch
this is grossman and that ball will be
caught
margot coming in margot with a sliding
catch in left field but for a moment the
way this game has gone and as big as
this outfield is you're worried about
anything that goes up leaves it up to
jamer candelario the 2-2
pounded deep right field that's got a
chance it's gone
chamber candelario steps up
and steps into one to tie it at seven
don't you dare not believe
what a day for jamer candelario
the 1-1
up the middle oh what a play by harold
castro show that leather oh that was
flashy
what a way to end the 11th castro with a
defensive web gem faces remain full but
now there's two outs 3-1 to grossman
walked him
and the tigers literally walk it off
[Applause]
you